Andrew Whitworth back here in the
program how you been Andrew I'm doing
good rich appreciate you having me oh
man you bet always well how would you do
on your bye week uh you know what we
called it a prep week rich or wasn't a
bar week okay what is that you know you
know now it was more about honestly
getting ourselves ready and prepared
physically and mentally for this week I
mean so it's less about getting away and
getting that break like you have in
season and I really thought we treated
it really goes kind of a pop a couple
days and then the rest of time working
you know not necessarily like getting
out on the field and practicing but you
know working out and doing some study of
ourselves throughout the season and
things that we did good or bad and what
we can do better really to be as
efficient as we need to be in the
playoffs you watch football and on - I
guess Scout who's coming your way
potentially oh yeah watched all the
games and and you know it's kind of know
a little bit about everybody that maybe
in the future that you're gonna have to
play and obviously it all starts this
week with the Dallas Cowboys before we
turn to that I'll turn you into part of
the paparazzi here Andrew which
performance surprised you the most for
what you watch this weekend you know I
think that honestly a lot of the games
went pretty similar to how I thought I
thought that you know Baltimore I don't
know some reason I kind of thought they
might be able to repeat their
performance being at home and how
dominant they were and you know really
they did play good our defense just
didn't find enough offensively to win
the game but that was one as good as I
think the charges are I think they're
really special I just thought that
Baltimore has kind of some of that
playoffs that you've seen win just good
defense a great running game you kind of
see that win this time of year
especially at home and that one kind of
somewhat I thought they would be a
little better earlier in the game than
they were well I mean it's just maybe
again it's just so difficult for a
first-timer to win a playoff game at the
quarterback position and as you know
last year with Atlanta coming in last
year to Los Angeles and and what was
able to be done to the offense that we
hadn't seen very much out of your Rams
offense last year and Jared Goff I mean
what what is it about a first-time
playoff experience Andrew
I think you know what I think for
everybody not just the quarterback
it'sit's that uh you know what the
efficiency level really just just making
sure you don't make mistakes that put
yourself behind the sticks and really
hurting your football team there's got
to be something that you understand and
playoff football both teams are great
you know you're not gonna get the gimme
bomb plays and just you know kind of
embarrassing each other you're gonna
have to earn every yard and playoff
football and so you know really that
efficiency of doing the little things
really well is what you have to do to
win playoff games and you see it I mean
it's all the way Indy went into Houston
and just the efficiency they had in the
first half I mean just every time you
have the balls finding a way to get that
first down and and then the big plays
will come eventually and so you know I
think that's the thing I think that's
something we all learned from last year
together as a group and Jared as well
and I think we all look forward to this
opportunity coming up four-time Pro
Bowler Andrew Whitworth offensive tackle
here on the Rich Eisen show the sense
that dead golf is not the same
quarterback since that night when you
guys were on tilt against the Chiefs on
Monday Night Football or what is is
something different about him as
something been different from your
perspective Andrew no I really feel like
you know what the quarterback wears at
all so if you're winning and your role
and the quarterback is going to get all
the praise in the world and if you have
a bad stretch where you list two games
in a row
the quarterbacks gonna take the heat and
you know what I think it's really it
truly is about all 11 yeah there's some
plays and situations that Jared would
love to have back but also I think that
we've helped put him in some of those
situations where maybe we're in a
situation where a big play hausky made
and he's forcing the ball or makes the
decision because we're not playing well
enough around him so you know I think it
really goes hand in hand it's everybody
on offense man it always has been
sometimes you can have a dominant
defensive player that makes the defense
good but offensively you know they all
11 is going to come in to factor and
eventually that's going to matter more
than anything else and so I think for us
these last couple weeks so we've gotten
back to doing what we do well and that's
being efficient this crap all across the
field and guys just doing their jobs and
doing it well and Jared has played
you know how the expectedly play and I
think that we got to do that we got to
play well around maybe give him the
opportunity to be confident and go make
those plays because people forgetting
still a very extremely young quarterback
in this league with a ton of talent and
we got to continue to put him in
opportunities to go be successful and
obviously a balanced offense is a way to
help that situation out CJ Anderson came
in last two weeks and was just fantastic
how is Gurley looking in your estimation
you can tell he's feeling better and we
look forward to having him back and then
he's a dominant football player and
somebody that's all really special in
the huddle and just on the field I mean
he's you know his mentality this
positivity carries over the guys and so
you know I think that we look forward
having him back but man what a job CJ's
done and we've really found kind of you
know something special there with him
and I'll mix we're just a marriage of
him in Austin and our running game has
really been well there's a couple weeks
and looks good and I hope hopefully can
continue that you know it I think we
feel good about where we are and really
you know the opportunity you have in
front of us so you know it's funny to
lose two games and talk to me the other
day you know we're 13 and 3 and feeling
bad about ourselves it's it's a bad
thing to be
you know what these last few weeks we
kind of got back to being us and the
defense is playing well we're looking
forward to our opportunity and and the
sense that Zeke's coming to town
offensive line that gets a lot of praise
is what's what sort of pride is on the
line with you and girly and the rest of
your teammates on the line knowing that
Dallas is coming in with that sort of
credit being given on that front those
guys in past years and have a special
group I think that there's a lot of good
football players over there and Zeke is
obviously a really special one and so
you know what we know they're gonna play
well and do their thing but we believe
in ourselves and we were willing to bet
on ourselves I think we look forward to
this matchup we look forward to the
opportunity to find on a way to win and
that's what playoff football is about
it's not about stats about big plays and
who's this or that it's about what teams
you know find the efficiency cuz 60
minutes to find a way to win the game
and I think that's the only focus we
have is what
gave us a victory and I look forward to
it I'll tell you what we're excited and
I think this is a neat opportunity first
time in 13 years I've had a bar week so
I look forward to feeling good and fight
in the game no kiddin first time in a
baker's dozen years for prep week though
right man drew prep week yeah prep we
want you get em come come on now I've
got your back just like you used to
having people's backs I understand that
what does the what challenged is Dallas
present well I mean obviously we've seen
him these last six seven weeks that
defenses just continued to seem better
and better every week and you know I
think that the upfront it's a similar
team they'll probably Philadelphia a
little bit and the fact that they got a
lot of great rushers they got a lot of
guys that can rotate in there that can
rush the quarterback and and try and
play coverage behind it and make you
check the ball down and those kind of
things and and they've done a really
good job of shifting and moving and
being able to stop the run game but
those guys at the same time and I think
that their defense is going to be you
know obviously with some really good
athletes at linebacker a tough team that
they all have today you want but I think
that you know what we look forward to
that challenge I mean if this is playoff
football which I expect is the best
challenge you've had all year and I
think we expect nothing less
Andrew you know I mean congrats by the
way I'm being named Walter Payton Man of
the Year nominee for your team that's
that's that's pretty huge stuff man
and you know we we talked last time we
spoke it was prior to where it looked
like you were going to play Mexico then
it didn't when so much was going on here
here locally how is everything in the
community there in Thousand Oaks just a
few weeks later Andrew what we can do
with the fires and really everything
else has happened and so I think that
you know that's a that's a process force
that guys off the field and their off
time or still have an opportunity to do
stuff with I mean Jared himself has been
busy with that and finding ways to raise
money and to just try and help people
out in this town so I think that's
something we'll continue to deal with
and you know for the time being and
having been through Hurricane Katrina
when I was at LSU my senior year I kind
of know that process and it's just it's
you know there's the immediate
people that kind of react and then they
say you know what there's still a lot of
work left to do
to help people out that are going
through adversity so we're gonna stick
in there and do everything we can as
athletes to try and help our communities
we look forward to that challenge as
well but you know what it's it's fun man
that you get to see opportunities and
adversity sometimes I found the bright
part just seeing how the people pull
together and seeing how people step up
for one another man it just reminds you
what's so precious about life and also
amazing your good man sir your good man
good luck to you this weekend Congrats
on making it through your prep week and
getting ready for the Cowboys
you got it Sam you Andrew Whitworth at a
Whitworth 77 on Twitter so Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience